Prime Minister Tom tabali
avoided being charged with the murder of
his second wife de Piniella when he
failed to show up in court on Friday two
weeks ago his third wife my SIA was
charged with ordering the shooting of a
predecessor as well as the attempted
murder of another woman wounded in the
attack in 2017 the Prime Minister's
no-show in court and the scandal
surrounding the murder is a hot topic in
the capital massero the baha'i giant's
theatre group performs at a taxi rank
bringing to life the controversy within
the suit whose political elite are you
really saying to me as a prime minister
you expect me to go to court from the
crowd and overwhelming yes this is a
chance for people captivated by the
intrigue to have their say once
spectator shouts that no one is above
the law and that Abani is wanted by the
police
another blames the Prime Minister for
dividing the country and demands he goes
to court this man accuses to Barney of
being a thief moments of humour in the
crisis here
much like the political leadership in
Lesotho people's opinion here is divided
despite his denial some think the Prime
Minister's on the run he says is in
South Africa for a medical check-up
either way his disappearance from court
is seen by many has been convenient as
they conclude their performance the
actors sing mimicking the Prime Minister
and his wife from a video she posted on
social media last year where they
appeared in bathrobes singing a
well-known song about seeking power it
was met with shock and criticism and
fuelled speculation that the
eight-year-old to Bonnie's third wife is
influencing politics in Mohawk Wayne
Huerta bonny is from the prime minister
retains some support on my side I want
to give him a chance to lead his country
and drop these murder charges
tibarn is under pressure from within his
own party to resign
he says he'll retire in July for now the
intrigue about his whereabouts and his
evasion of justice goes on famila mela
al jazeera Masaru Lesotho